we can speak to ali fortescue who joins
me now from westminster and
some confirmation from the liverpool
city region about the level
of lockdown that they can expect that's
right in the last half hour we've spoken
to local leaders in liverpool they say
they've had another discussion
with government this afternoon and it
has been agreed we understand that they
will be under tier three restrictions
that is the highest covered alert level
that we
expect will be announced tomorrow we
understand from speaking to those local
leaders
that that will involve the closure of
gyms
casinos pubs bars it won't involve the
closure of schools
universities or interestingly
restaurants and how exactly they're
going to distinguish
between pubs and restaurants remains to
be seen we understand it'll be something
to do with
um whether a pub offers a substantive
meal as we've been told so where they'll
draw in the lab
the line with that will be interesting
to see and there's also the question
of funding and we understand that
leaders are expecting a financial
contribution for test and trace
but they have yet to agree a financial
contribution for
local authorities for further funding
from the government
so i think expect that issue of money
the issue of finances
more money to help with more
restrictions to come up again and again
we've heard
a lot of pushback from politicians of
all colors over the weekend a little
earlier on the leader of bolton
council was saying that he thinks the
funding settlement at the moment
is unacceptable so i think expect plenty
more pushback
on that from politicians on all sides
over the next
few days and we know that tomorrow the
prime minister will be addressing
parliament and giving us all some more
clarity on which parts of the country
will
be subject to which rules